pal 68 pour sa traditionnelle
présentation de la rentrée une
présentation qu'on puisse suivre pour
nous ça binck fr et vincent le miel oui
je me trouve dans le collège robert
schuman de saint-amarin ou plutôt un
énorme chantier car ce collège de 500
élèves va subir un lifting complet qui
va durer cinq ans et qui va coûter plus
de 10 millions d'euros et ce collège est
l'un des 10 à subir de grandes
transformations ces prochains temps pour
cette rentrée
les chantiers sont aussi différents et
l'un concerne le bilinguisme comme nous
l'expliquent brigitte king art président
du conseil départemental y aura ici dans
l'espace rhénan
le bilinguisme est très important ce
sont dans les 15 prochaines années
trente mille salariés qui seront
recrutés 30000 salariés bilingue
donc notre objectif c'est que demain
tous les jeunes alsaciens tous les
jeunes collégiens soit bilingue français
allemand d'ici quelques jours c'est donc
la rentrée est dans le haut rhin ils
seront trente six mille collégiens à
reprendre le chemin de l'école
l'avenir de l'alsace en discute